without a world's being a new game that
gives the player a fresh new environment
to discover filled with vast landscapes
notorious creatures and likable
companions today's gonna be one of many
lore videos within the series of outer
worlds and today we're going to be
talking about companions and to be even
more specific the first one that you
meet and my personal favorite Parvati
you first meet Parvati in the Emerald
Vale in Edgewater on Terra - you
interrupt a conversation between her and
Reed Thompson the main mayor of the area
Reed asks you to go to a nearby plant
and direct power from there to Edgewater
and not where Adelaide is and says that
Parvati may be of some use to you coming
with you
you can choose to ignore this request or
accept it if you happen to decline the
first time you can always come back to
his office and she will still be there
and you can ask for her to party up with
you after exiting the office she talks
to you about you probably not wanting
her to tag along and you just said that
to get out of the way this is kind of
where her shyness starts to come in and
not wanting to cause any trouble you
explained to her either through some
nice or aggressive means that you want
her as part of the team which is why you
offered to accept you go to ask about
town and what they think about Reed and
she explains how she hears noise but not
really word she mostly keeps to herself
and keeps her eyes down and doesn't
really like to get into anybody's way in
terms of her views on the place she
still hasn't come up with what is there
going to be her exact choice but she
does want to evaluate both sides and go
over the right and wrong then decide it
which is what her dad always told her
you can actually perception check her
about this message and then she
basically states that her and her mom
really never met or she never really met
her mom her dad raised her all on his
own her mom had a contract stating
basically that any shoulder that she had
either expected or unexpected were going
to be sent to wherever they needed to at
the time of birth meaning she will most
likely not see the child and then when
that happens she was sent to her with
her dad and then she never got to meet
her current building we're in is
actually her house she has tons of
things to say every time you enter the
room like offering to give you food
giving you privacy in the bathroom how
she doesn't like to go on the balcony
cos people stare at her and just
generally nice things to say to you you
could check her terminal to see her
current work orders like an Ag loader
and the cannery production line
malfunctioning you can even go up to her
office where she says that it used to be
her dad's but then retracts saying that
it's hers now
he's eventually found out through
Adelaide or by eventually talking with
her that her dad had passed away about a
year or so ago going to her dad's
computers you see that the last search
term was Indumati which is the name of
her mom two notes are shown here one
being a diary entry in the other letter
from Indu money to Robert to her which
is her father in domani left Edgewater
today she's being assigned to Tara one I
kissed her goodbye at the platform and
asked if I'd ever see her again we both
knew the answer was no look and think of
me as I look up and think of you the
second letter says dear Robert they
wouldn't let me keep her but I know
you'll race her with love perhaps more
than I would make time for your patient
and present in a way that I am NOT the
company says she has no name until you
give her one her name is Parvati they
tell me her birthday is the day that
she'll be legally delivered to you but
it's actually July 7th make her special
when I can't she like that when I sang
to her it was the only time she had
stopped crying it is clear though that
why she is upset losing her father and
her mother can be hard for someone to
endure it on a happier note it's good to
see her doing well even with her current
situation she also has two places as
well that can trigger dialogue one in
the general store and one in the bar
when you walk into the bar she asks if
you're a heavy drinker or not she points
out that she lives right across the road
she sees a lot of people walking in
happy tired or sad and then grabbing
some drinks then drunkenly stumbling out
of the bar not really worried about
their current situation or stumbling
into a Nellie and crying this is one of
the main reasons why she doesn't drink
at the general store the owner mentions
how she is not allowed inside after an
incident she had when she was 12 when
asked why julius moreau the store's
owner says you should ask her and just
like any child basically she wanted to
know how stuff worked and was just being
a curious kid she tried to pick the lock
on one of the vending machines to see
how they refill them but when she opened
it a bunch of zero-g bottles had fallen
everywhere at the same exact time some
loader BOTS came through with packages
and they all ended up slipping on the
bottles and spilling it all over Reed
Thompson even though she's got to be
somewhere between 19 and her mid-20s by
now the owner still won't let her in
it's very clear that he still hasn't
grudge about this eventually Parvati
will
that you should talk to vicar max for
some guidance once again you can mention
her about the cleanliness comment that
she comments about because of being at
church she says that something that's
dirty should show work and that it's
been used and that she doesn't really
like the fact that everything is so
clean
obviously vicar max and Parvati have two
different lines of work if you stepped
into a mechanic shop and then went into
a place of holiness or a church you'll
totally notice the huge difference in
cleanliness and stuff like that so it's
really just based off the fact that
they've seen two different things and
they experienced two different lines of
work so obviously they'll be opposed in
which is cleanliness and which is not
talking to vicar max he points out how
Parvati doesn't really say much or never
wants to speak with him you can mention
how dismissive that is and how
inappropriate is for a vicar to be doing
that he denies and claims that he simply
be moaning about the town in his line of
work not really many people in Edgewater
believe in a higher power above us and
since that's his job to raise that he's
not exactly doing the best job at it
there's a lot of Max to go over in this
section but we really aren't here for
him so we'll visit him in another
episode so stay tuned for that
eventually afterwards you make it to
Adelaide's camp and you meet a guy named
thomas who has a crush on Parvati very
clearly and he mentions how he's always
wanted to be an engineer just like her
and which is some serious dedication you
can ask more about this encounter and
she won't mentioned that Thomas was one
of a few nice people to her never yelled
at her never made fun of her because of
how she is just sat and watched her work
and she prefers to think of them that
way and not anything more game continues
on with you talking about Adelaide about
her side but let's and fast-forward to
the decision part Parvati finally has
her mind set and she thinks the
Edgewater actually deserves the power
since there's more people there and they
work hard enough as it is choosing to
take this into account is up to you if
you choose not to take her advice
talking to Reid is obvious obviously
going to be mad and that you turned off
the power he does eventually send his
guards after you but you can of course
speech check this to make them not but
if you want to he can actually shoot you
on sight if you chose Edgewater for
power she says this
she basically just says that she cares
for the people of Edgewater regardless
of how much they care about her which is
kind of wholesome yet upsetting at the
exact same time you can also talk to
Adelaide where she confronts you about
her decision she has a counter objective
which is to kill Reed Thompson which you
may or may not have experienced in your
own game if you do actually accept this
and do go through with it Parvati will
actually be upset and leave your party
because you killed her boss even though
she was cool with it in the other option
when he started attacking you regardless
of the option you take you take the
power regulator and head off to your
ship Parvati being an engineer likes to
stay near the workstation she mentioned
how she got this job because of an
aptitude test everyone basically and
during school and such took an aptitude
test that determined their profession
she got engineered just like her father
and a lot of people became suspicious
that she cheated and her father helped
her which we all know was then
definitely not the case since she liked
to spend a lot of time with her dad and
since her dad did a lot of engineering
she just knew what he was doing whatever
you got on this test you basically went
right out of school for into your
profession after you learned how to do
the trades of your job whatever it
happened to be picked
so you basically right out of school got
to your first job wherever the company
had an opening so there might be you
might even be shipped to a whole new
planet and you might not able to be
seeing your parents again kind of like
how her mother and father had to
separate because of a job but just
judging from how Parvati speaks about
engineering it's very clear that she
does enjoy her job sometimes she gets a
little bit too focused into it and just
works on one order and all the quirks
and everything that's happening with the
particular order that she forgets that
she has other orders to do and miss his
deadline so she really isn't the most
reliable worker but she does do the job
really well and she's trying her hardest
which is ultimately the best part this
is where the turning point of her
character comes in when you first get to
ground breaker she mentions about
another engineer called Jun Lai who she
would like to meet talking to Jim Lee
you can obviously tell that Parvathi is
very flustered and shy when talking with
her she eventually gets Jun leis number
essentially and they basically talk
about spaceship stuff learning how to
repair since she's very new to this she
knows how to repair other stuff just not
a giant spaceship and obviously she
wants to do good because now she's the
engineer of your ship when you
eventually go back to the ship
you can talk to bar Vaati and you can
ask her stuff saying that Jun Lee had
been
and you her more and more and that she
ended up writing her a poem she seems
nervous as she hasn't seen the poem but
when she does look at it she looks even
more nervous because in the poem it
mentions about an old girl named Isabel
but you can assure her that it's the
past is the past and Isabel probably
doesn't matter anymore she eventually
says that she wants to get a drink to
ease her mind off of stuff even though
before she mentioned out she doesn't
want to drink so this was definitely a
huge change within the storyline for her
so you end up going to the last hope on
a groundbreaker to grab some drinks you
have beer whiskey some other options but
none of them really matter it's all
going to lead you to the same part in
the past basically June they had a crush
on this girl Isabel they ended up dating
a little bit but June lays dad never
approved of it and then slowly after
that the relationship basically crumbled
so they had broken up but after heading
back a June label message parvathi again
and she will tell you about this
basically confessing her love for her
but in the worst way possible of trying
to convey it after some time just going
through the game and landing back
account and groundbreaker again she will
mention that this is the time to do it
and she's not going to beat her on the
bush he's going to ask out June lay but
she is worried about her appearance so
she wants to gather some things you're
gonna need some soap from glad he's at
ground breaker you're gonna need to cast
a role from chef Raymond it's Teller Bay
and some sweetheart cakes you'll find in
Cascadia on monarch and some dress
clothes in Byzantium so a lot of stuff
and it's gonna be costing you a lot of
bits if you don't speech check the
clothes everything will cost you about
9000 bits
6k for the clothes and 3k for the
casserole but if you do speech check it
whether through intimidation or
persuasion it will be about 6000 bits so
still a hefty price once that's all set
and ready you basically just let the
date start the game goes to black and
you come back and they're just talking
of course to progress through this you
have to leave the ship and then come
right back but you can chill a little
bit in the corner and kind of listen to
what they're talking about nothing
really interesting learning about more
of her past doesn't really come up just
casual talk between the two of them just
talking which is really nice to hear but
after leaving the ship and giving them
their privacy you come back and you want
to hear all about the details she meant
since how she enjoyed the soap and
almost cried when she saw the castle
rolling cakes and that she was nervous
in the beginning but got more
comfortable with her later which is
always nice and that of course that they
are now officially a couple which is
really nice to hear and that's
practically the end she went from the
shop
engineered to a now a more bold and more
forward engineer now thanks to you in
helping her with your quests and that's
pretty much the lore on Parvati now in
terms of the endings you can actually
get two separate endings depending on
which you pick whether you skip the hope
- Tara - and end up getting the good
ending with Phineas or skip the hope to
Tartarus and get the bad ending
basically they all start the same they
are of course all basically still dating
June Leia and Parvati and she action
June they actually asked if Parvati
wants to join her permanently on the
ground breaker if you do decide to go
with the good ending she continues to be
this center of attention which he is
more than comfortable with handling now
which is really nice serving as the
engineer on the renowned spacecraft with
a bunch of other people and she and Jun
they were practically always together
whereas if you picked the bad ending
they still get to work on the ground
breaker but she's still constantly being
worried and gets dreams of freezing to
death because of the lifetime employment
program and because of that Jun lay
struggles to keep the ground breaker
afloat because Parvathi isn't really at
her utmost possible and then eventually
their relationship ends up falling out
and Parvati moves into the crew quarters
and finds herself working on water pumps
in the hydroponics section so really not
a great ending the Phineas ending is
definitely the better of the two yeah
let me know what you guys think about
this lore video and the comments below
super excited to do a lot more for this
game and honestly this I wanted to do
the Parvati one first because this was
ultimately my favorite character and
definitely one of my favorite lore
videos to do honestly it was just super
cool to think about and look at and
privada is honestly one of the best
companions in the game
see I definitely let me know about this
stuff in the comments below let me know
what you guys think about Parvati as
well if you ended up completing her
requestor or maybe you like one of the
companions more like max Felix le Nyoka
even Sam just let me know in the
comments below when that guys like to be
if you do enjoy subscribe before you and
take care guys have a great day
you
[Music]